nous est brodé richard henry je risque
pas de me perdre avec ça j'ai 85 ans en
utah à l'ehpad de saint françois
d'assise à saint denis
prophétie ben on essaye de survivre
je suis tout mon épouse physiquement
elle et elle est au top mais avec l'ama
diabeo malause
chez vous sur pas pour moi c'est une
personne qui a une vie active très
riches ne veut pas dire simplement une
vie professionnelle en tant qu'expert
comptable mais une vie active très riche
dans beaucoup de domaines dans le
domaine social économique dans le
domaine culturel cultuel
je vous présenter notre animatrice elle
est formidable
ils pensent parfois avoir été un peu
oubliée du fait qu' il soit dans la
retraite est hors circuit mais je pense
qu'au contraire il peut toujours
apporter beaucoup dans le milieu
associatif
j'ai plus de contacts et de métis et edu
un métier de contact
j'ai plus de contact avec personne 2 oui
nous le printemps en chantant bras
dominique le soleil s'est fait beau j'ai
le coeur comme une boîte à musique
j'espère ne serait pas ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui ce qu'il a été et n'auraient
pas accompli toutes ces actions si ma
mère n'avait pas été à côté de lui 2
donc 12 et chaud j'ai envie d'être des
nobilo